one of the things that Donald Trump has
said a number of times now to try to
convince people that impeaching him is a
bad idea
is he's been saying the stock market
would crash if I got impeached now it's
not a crazy thing to suggest markets in
general don't like instability the
removal of a president or even the
attempted removal of a president is a
form of instability so it is reasonable
to think wow if Trump were impeached if
Trump were impeached and convicted for
removal the markets would absolutely
crash and Donald Trump has kept pushing
this lately he tweeted late last week
quote if they actually did this the
markets would crash do you think it was
luck that got us to the best stock
market and economy in our history it
wasn't so put aside for a second that
most stocks are held by relatively few
people richer people and so the level of
the stock market is not the best
indicator of the health of the economy
put that aside just for a second okay
there's a good case to be made that
markets would actually do really well
and might even soar rather than crash if
Donald Trump were impeached Rick Newman
from Yahoo Finance makes the case for
this and Rick points out that number one
markets have been relatively stable
since the impeachment inquiry was
announced you've actually seen very few
big swing days one way or the other
since the impeachment inquiry was
announced that's the first sign that we
should question this so-called
conventional wisdom of impeachment is
terrible for the markets but Rick Newman
actually says markets would soar if
Trump was impeached because the things
that Donald Trump has done which tend to
boost stocks now this is for better or
worse this is not me saying I agree with
these policies but Trump has done tax
cuts and deregulation very often that
boosts stocks of course there's a it's
it's there's an expense to that as well
which we can talk about those would in
principle stay if Donald Trump were
removed but a lot of the bad things
Trump has done would likely end the
tariffs the xenophobia interfering with
free markets even on things like
immigration immigration is great for the
economy the gains from immigration even
including undocumented immigration are
far greater than the costs to the
economy now this all has a cost to it
right low wages poor conditions for many
legal and illegal immigrants I'm not
making a moral analysis here I'm merely
making an economic one for the sake of
discussion and there is a strong case to
be made that if Donald Trump were
impeached and removed it would not crash
the stock market the way Donald Trump is
pointing out now there's a bigger
argument which is if the right thing to
do for legal reasons on the basis of the
evidence for moral reasons is to impeach
a president you do it you don't make the
calculation that in the short term the
market won't like it so we let a
president remain president who shouldn't
be president that's a separate argument
what we're talking about merely is the
practicality and the logistics of the
market will crash versus the market will
soar if Trump is impeached let me give
you another example the craziness with
Iran what's bad for markets is the
instability with Iran which would
probably calm down if Donald Trump was
removed from office now Rick Newman is
also saying that if Trump were replaced
with pence the economy would be much
better off
I find pence disgusting and it would be
terrible but the main point here that
Rick Newman is making and which i think
is a valid point to make or at least to
propose is that Donald Trump's removal
would not be terrible for the economy as
a foregone conclusion and we need to
challenge all of those ideas merely
because they might have been accurate 20
years ago merely because it seems to
make some intuitive sense does not mean
that we should fall for it hook line and
sinker and more importantly one way or
the other this is not the basis on which
impeachment should be decided upon